fire axes just announced a new XCOM
spin-off called chimera squad and it's
changing up the formula in some big ways
here's what you need to know first this
isn't a sequel it's a standalone
spin-off that set five years after XCOM
two humans and aliens are actually
working together but some of Earth's
natives aren't happy about it
chimera squad includes both human and
alien soldiers and they investigate
threats to this new inner species
Alliance each squad member has their own
unique abilities which is a huge
departure from the series customizable
cannon fodder soldiers making random
roles each member also gets their own
turn during combat there isn't one macro
phase for your turn followed by the
enemies every unit has their own place
in the timeline and some of those unique
abilities can manipulate who gets to act
first
you can even stack some of these
abilities together for powerful combo
attacks these combat encounters take
place in discrete locations in a single
city each mission is self-contained with
multiple shifting objectives
you'll start each mission with the new
breach mode which lets you choose your
initial starting point on the map some
of these starting points can only be
used by humans or aliens and where you
begin the mission will change the flow
of your objectives within this is all
leading up to chimera squads biggest
change there is no permit earth if a
squad member goes down they begin
bleeding out if they don't stabilize
within a few turns they'll die which
restarts the mission however game overs
are still possible each mission takes
place in a different sector with their
own levels of unrest if you let one
sector get too unruly the chaos will
overtake the entire city
chimera squad sounds like a pretty big
departure from standard XCOM and you can
try it out for yourself on April 24th
it'll cost you just 10 US dollars when
it hits steam that day but the price
will go up to 20 on May 1st
stay tuned a GameSpot as we learn more
about the surprise new spinoff
[Music]